- [Instructor] As we get into the 1500s,
the Renaissance has been going
on for roughly 200 years.
Especially Europe has been
rediscovering the knowledge
from the Greeks and from
the Romans and as they enter
into the 16th century,
they start to go beyond
the knowledge of the
Greeks and the Romans.
In 1543, Nicolaus Copernicus
publishes On the Revolutions
of the Heavenly Spheres, famous
for suggesting that earth
is not the center of the
universe but that the earth
revolves around the sun.
What was powerful about this
is it challenged centuries old
ideas about how the universe
worked and at a meta level,
it was about using new methods
and evidence in order to make
conclusions no matter how revolutionary
those conclusions might be.
And this publication is
often cited as the beginning
of what will be known as
the scientific revolution.
Many people view the capstone
of the scientific revolution
to be Newton's publication
of Principia in 1687
and this is an incredibly
powerful publication.
It describes the laws of the universe,
it's a universe in which
most things can be explained
with simple principles, with mathematics.
This is so powerful that
it would not be challenged
for over 200 years until Albert
Einstein comes on the scene
with his theories of relativity.
But even today, Newton's
laws, this is what is taught
in a first year physics
class, this is what you learn
in an introductory engineering class,
so there's many things to think about,
why did this happen at
this period of time,
how was it related to the Renaissance,
how was it related to
things that were happening
in politics in Europe at the time?
But needless to say, it gave
humanity a new perspective
on the universe and it
gave humanity new powers
and we began to challenge all assumptions
and so as we get into the
late 1600s and early 1700s,
people start trying to
use these same tools,
the same deductive reasoning
on some of the oldest questions
that humanity has ever asked itself,
questions like, what rights
do we have as human beings?
Who gets those rights?
What duty and obligation do
we have towards each other?
What is the role of government?
Who has the right to rule?
Now some of these questions
have been the fodder
of philosophers and religion
for thousands of years.
But now there was the power and the tools
and the challenging notions
of the scientific revolution.
And this philosophical
movement that is really tied
to the scientific revolution
is known as the Enlightenment.
And just to have an
example of the thinking
during the Enlightenment, here
is a passage from John Locke
who is considered one of the
pillars of the Enlightenment.
This is published in 1689,
it's the Second Treatise
Concerning Civil Government.
"The state of nature has a
law of nature to govern it,
which obliges everyone and
reason, which is that law,"
so reason is the law
of nature to govern it,
"teaches all mankind
who will but consult it
"that being all equal and
independent, no one ought to harm
"another in his life, health,
liberty, or possessions.
"And when his own preservation
comes not in competition,
"ought he as much as he can to
preserve the rest of mankind
"and may not unless it be to
do justice on an offender,
"take away or impair
the life or what tends
"to the preservation of the
life, the liberty, health,
"limb or goods of another."
Now to parse what he's
saying, he says that reason
is this natural law that
should govern human action
and he's saying no one
ought to harm anyone else
and that if we're not in competition,
maybe there's only
enough food for one of us
and there's two of us
there, in which case we'd be
in competition, but if there
isn't that competition,
we should be trying to help
each other and we should
be trying to preserve the rest of mankind.
And unless it's for
the purpose of justice,
you don't have the right to
take away or impair the life
or things that help preserve
the life, the liberty,
the health, limb, or goods of another.
Now you might say, hey,
isn't this common sense?
And religions for all of
time have touched on some
of these issues but you
also have to appreciate
that this is a time when kings
and emperors ruled the world.
What gave them that right?
Why are certain people slaves
and other people not slaves?
Why do certain people in that world
have a right to own these other people?
And so this was a very controversial idea,
challenging some of
these fundamental notions
of who should rule, who
has the right to rule,
and to what degree should
people exert control
over one another, so given
these challenging notions
of the Enlightenment, and
John Locke was only one
of the actors who would figure prominently
in this roughly 100-year
period, it's no surprise
that as you get into the
late 1700s and early 1800s,
you have a whole string of revolutions,
especially in the Americas,
to a large degree inspired
by the ideas of the
Enlightenment, things like life,
liberty, health, in the
United States Declaration
of Independence, these things are cited.
During the French Revolution,
these things are cited.
In the various revolutions
in Latin America,
these ideas are cited.
Now one of the reasons
why the Enlightenment
came about when it did, not
only did we have new tools
of thinking and the opportunity
to challenge notions,
but it might have been
that society now had
the responsibility to
think a little bit deeper
about these ideas because
it was getting more and more
powers through the scientific revolution.
And those powers were
becoming even more significant
when that science was applied
during the Industrial Revolution.
Now society could produce
more than it could ever
produce before, but as we
talk about in other videos,
the Industrial Revolution
had a certain hunger
for raw materials and a
certain hunger for markets
in which to sell your finished product.
It also allowed for more
powerful weapons and ways
to project power and to
control a larger empire,
methods of communication,
methods of force,
and many historians tie
it directly to the age
of imperialism where especially
Western European powers
sought areas to get raw
materials and markets
in which they could push
their finished products
and so as the industrialized
world had more and more power,
these ideas of the Enlightenment
became maybe even more
relevant even though they
might not have been implemented
consistently during
the age of imperialism.
And as we've seen in other videos,
even though the technology
keeps accelerating
during the Industrial
Revolution, the philosophy
and the moral framework does
not accelerate along with it
and in 20th century, we see
one of the bloodiest centuries
in all of human history,
so let me leave you
with a final series of questions.
As we go into the 1800s,
we talked about the various
independence movements
especially in the Americas,
we also have the abolishing of slavery
in most of the world around
this time period and so to some
degree, it looks like the
ideas of the Enlightenment
are coming to be, but
at the exact same time,
you have the age of imperialism,
where more and more control
is exerted over people around the planet.
This all comes to a head in
World War I, which is one
of the bloodiest conflicts
in all of human history.
So to what degree did the
Enlightenment help the world
and to what degree did
it not get fulfilled?
Or maybe in some way,
things like World War I
and World War II were the birthing pangs,
the transition state,
from the world before
the Enlightenment, then
how close are we truly
to those ideals today?
In a future video, I'm
gonna talk about that
and I'm gonna talk about
the idea of human rights
and how we as a civilization
have attempted to address it
after World War II.